what do I think of the new name I think
it should have been named after a
chemist rather than an astronomer or
possibly a physicist as no chemist would
invent something so utterly pointless
where we going we'll go to my office but
I've just got a couple of things to do
that I have to do beforehand I got a
call off here about five minutes ago and
I just been dragged out of a research
meeting with my group and I got the call
off well at the text message on my
iPhone and it was amazing the the
fantastic naming of element number one
one two and it's only taken was it ten
years or something to name it since
discovery I thought I'd Google the new
element well I can see on the BBC web
page of this Penelope it's been named
copernicium and I read a little bit
further down the story and it's been
named after Nicholas Copernicus the
astronomer what's all that about he's
not a chemist so they finally named the
new element I would have called it
Copernican caperna see'em is not easy to
pronounce and I think's gonna cause a
lot of difficulty for some chemists or
not English or even English ones as well
but it's quite a strange choice because
Copernicus was a very famous astronomer
but I'm not really sure what he had to
do with chemistry in fact the word
chemistry was only invented about 60 or
70 years after Copernicus died at least
invented in the English language yeah
it's quite an unusual name the
historical name of course do you think
it'll get mixed up for copper
that's not an usual question I suppose
it could in principle that's right it
could yes and I think it may cause
problems for people whose first language
isn't brows English
I think it's nice because for the first
time we have broken away from this
nationalistic idea that you must name
somebody from your own country if you're
choosing elements so that's really
positive on the other hand it would have
been nice to have slightly more
connection with chemistry but let's go
and look at the periodic table so this
one this one's a periodic t-shirt it was
given to me it glows in the dark
actually if you switch off the lights I
don't if we can see that it's a glows a
bit but very conveniently it ends up
with element hundred and eleven
roentgenium which is totally
unpronounceable and now we're going to
see if the pen right if we can put C P
on here it's not very beautiful CP but
there it is in the right place on the
periodic table now CP is really not a
very good symbol because most inorganic
chemists like me use the simple CP to
stand for cyclopentadiene the C 5 H 5
ring now of course it's very unlikely
that in the when you're talking about
the cyclopentadienyl compound that
people will think you're talking about
Copernican but it's probably not very
good to have a symbol which could be
confused and see with a little p with
subscript is also used to mean there's
specific heat the amount of heat you
need to put into something to heat it up
by one degree centigrade so there are
possibilities for confusion but of
course there's still six months for
people to make points about this and
decide whether it's a good name or not
my feeling is that it should be called
Copernican without the letter i because
it's just so much easier to say rolls
off the tongue
so my vote is for Copernican what about
your ties and your umbrella and all your
different things with the periodic table
do you have to get new ones now
well I always need to get new ones and
so I'm hoping that the people who make
the time because my blue tie
ends up with 811 as well but there's
room for more so I hope those of you if
you're watching if you're manufacturing
ties I'm in the market for a new one or
you can send me one to advertise
hello what do I think of this um well it
wouldn't have been an obvious choice for
me but in retrospect I think it's
fantastic you know I'm all for an
astronomer being recognized in this way
if you look at the periodic table
there's a dozen other elements that are
named after scientists and very famous
chemists and physicists and given that
it's the International Year of astronomy
why not name the newest element after
one of our most famous astronomers so
Nicholas Copernicus we would probably
call him the father of modern day
astronomy and what he did was really
profoundly change how we view our place
in the universe so it kind of makes
sense given the observations that we see
around us given common sense that the
earth would be the center of the
universe we don't feel the earth moving
it looks like the Sun goes around the
earth but he really turned that around
by looking at the text by making
thousands of observations he realized
that it was simpler mathematically it
was a simpler explanation to put the Sun
at the center of all of these motions
not a lot perhaps but I'll take any
recognition that we can get the whole
idea the whole origin of the word
revolutionary comes from his discovery
because he published these these
theories in a book called the revolution
of the heavenly spheres and so it was
such a profound shift in our
understanding that we actually adopted
that word revolutionary to mean the
overthrowing of one established thing
for something new and radical well you
learn something new every day